and we are recording we are all set to
go
i have all of our amazing co-hosts here
with us and our
special guest that we are just so
honored to be able to host every friday
on ask doc live
my name is rebecca dukes kozak and i am
joined today by my co-host jonty
mccollier ruth ellen sanchez dr judy
reynolds heather bowen and nasima omar
and we
are here because we have this passion
to be able to share information that is
empowering
to
everybody
everybody's who's
ears here
were planting seeds
and our
hope is that those seeds will start to
grow in helping people realize
that there's a lot of different sciences
out there folks
some
factual some not so factual
but when it comes to having scientific
evidence through autopsies and through
research that is done
by the person who
actually did the autopsies and
comparison i mean there's so many things
that our special guest has done that has
supported the information that we are
sharing here on a stock live each and
every week
now ask doc live is sponsored by
askdoclive.com
but it is very important if this program
was shared with you by somebody specific
somebody that you met online somebody
that you know personally
get back with them
because
what we're sharing
or sharing as a resource
they have their own specific ways
that they can order the product that
you need in your hands
and since they're the ones that referred
you to this program make sure that you
get back with them
as a thank you
even if it's just to say thank you
verbally
but get back with them
if you want to order anything
and get more information about what you
hear today
again my name is rebecca dukes kozak and
i am going to be your host for the next
two hours of ask stock live
this program is not meant to treat
diagnose cure any diseases
we are here to provide information only
and just give an education
on how important it is
because our food supplies are empty
folks
they can say eat a healthy diet well
whose healthy diet is healthy
when you
all around the world and you're going to
hear it in today's presentation
minerals
are like
mar was it chocolate fudge ice cream
with those little swirls and every those
ribbons have fudge through it if they're
not even throughout the ground and if
the minerals are not in the ground the
food that is grown in that ground is not
going to have it
so that's where being intentional and
what you put in your mouth
and on your body and have around you
affects
how your body's genes are going to
respond
and that's proven in the science of
epigenetics epigenetics
is something that
our special guest today was part of
finding
as he is
one of the co-founders of the science of
epigenetics
now
as i had mentioned that the products
discussed are not intended to diagnose
treat cure prevent any
diseases
and the information contained in the
zoom is for informational purposes only
if you are pregnant nursing or taking
medications please consult your health
care professional before starting any
supplement program
now we are using food as medicine
and to guide us through what are the
best absorbable
options
we have the one the only dr joel wallach
welcome dr wallach to ask doc live
well thank you so much for the kind
introduction rebecca and thank you to
your whole team my gosh what an
illustrious team you have put together
here to get this information out
and it's so important this basic basic
basic stuff
and we want to give a little brief
information uh this morning on a disease
that's impacting humanity all around the
world is alzheimer's disease
and now there's so much misinformation
associated with it
and some of it was intentional
criminal misinformation and you know to
get grants and things like that and some
of it is just ignorance
well
um let's look at some basic stuff
oops
we can't have buglers on
when i'm talking
all right um
so get on them john t
any rates um what we do know
um is that
um
of people
over the age of 65 are diagnosed with
alzheimer's disease
of people over the age of 85 in america
are diagnosed with alzheimer's disease
um let's see here we know
that the
um and this goes back to 2006 when there
was a major paper published by the
university of minnesota
i think there is somewhere between
depending on who whose version you read
about this there's anywhere from
12 to 20 different co-authors and
contributors to this article
okay
and they came up with the idea
that the
basic cause
of
uh alzheimer's disease is an
accumulation of amyloid
plaque and this came out in 2006 2006
okay
well it turns out that 25 percent of the
normal brain weight of human beings is
cholesterol
25 of the normal brain weight of human
beings is cholesterol
when you look at scans of people with
alzheimer's disease when you look at
scans of people with ms multiple
sclerosis and guillain-barre syndrome
which is
ms in kids under the age of 25
same disease is ms
and alzheimer's disease has many of the
same
symptoms as ms and gamberry syndrome
and then of course
there's osteoporosis of the skull
uh which we have a book that's been out
now it's been out for and in use for oh
maybe 14
months couple months past two years
uh okay excuse me past a year uh out
and it was very obvious
that we hit the nail on the head
with that
and um
uh yesterday we had
a
a wonderful
um
meeting which we do every other week in
let's see here um in the philippines
okay and we had a gal in there she's
from new zealand
and she was 65 years old and she had
like 25 different
health issues that she was interested in
in herself
and
i'm getting
information here that um
there's a basic underlying problem here
and i answered one you know many
questions there you go and we'll get to
the
yeah
the cd is by the same title it's all on
your head
and we'll get to that in a minute of
course rebecca is a co-author on the cd
so she interviewed me and she did a
great job putting that together and
we'll get to that in a minute
well but but last night uh i asked this
gal uh she's 65 years old i asked her a
question
um
do you ever get up at night to urinate
because she had like 20 different
symptoms but she didn't say anything
about getting up at night
she said yes i do i said well how many
times
do you get up
once twice five times she says oh
eight ten twelve fifteen times i get up
i'm getting up every half hour to
yearning
okay well this is called polyuria you
know not like polly wants a cracker it's
not it's not kidney disease in in
parrots okay
but poly from the scientific standpoint
of meaning many okay urinations okay
and this is due to
osteoporosis of the skull squeezing the
spinal cord is coming out of the back of
the skull the spinal cord is telling the
urinary bladder to urinate
and it's not a prostate problem because
women don't have prostate glands but
women do have four times the rate of
odyssey approaches so it all kind of fit
and she was just like like went crazy
when i told her what her problem was and
her problem also contributed everything
else and this is where rebecca was
holding up the book it's all in your
head originally i thought there was 25
different diseases that were caused by
osteoporosis to the skull and i actually
got an award from the united nations
it's called lifetime achievement award
for natural medicine
they've only given out three of those
awards over the hundred years they've
been around it's not an annual award but
they give one something so i discovered
all this stuff going on with
osteoporosis of the skull
and these 25 different diseases it turns
out there's actually 37 different
diseases that are caused by osteoporosis
the skull and some of them are
also related to
ms multiple sclerosis because you get
the same symptoms of multiple sclerosis
and osteoporosis skull
and guillain-barre syndrome and
alzheimer's disease
and the subtitle of our
cd that rebecca and i did
is see here how to prevent and fix
osteoporosis to the skull and ms and
when we run out of these we're going to
have to reprint it we're also going to
add
how to prevent and fix osteoporosis of
the skull ms and alzheimer's disease
okay because we know the answer to all
these now and so we're very very excited
about this now if you buy the set if you
buy the book and the cd you get a nice
little discount if you buy 10 sets oh my
gosh you get a big discount we really
want to encourage you
and give you a big financial break if
you buy 10 of these sets
the book and the cd it's all in your
head
you will help your church community your
family community
your community at the place you work
your neighborhood
get the scouts
the boy scouts and cub scouts involved
get the girl scouts the brownies
involved
uh that's one of the things i did when i
started the company was because i
was a eagle scout and um
uh ordered the arrow and all that kind
of stuff
uh i was a scout master and so scouting
um is a great source
of warriors people who want to
contribute to the benefit of the
community that they're in
okay
excuse me
and what better
what better thing
for the girl scouts the boy scouts to do
than to give many healthy years to the
community they live in
okay
and so they get their merit badges and
they get their awards and so forth by
doing these community things
so get them involved
with youngevity get them the information
give them the tools teach them what they
need to know
um and so you know get them on
epigenetics the death of the jack theory
disease transmission get them the book
hell's kitchen uh which goes into all
the the bad things that happen
uh because of improper cooking
um nutritional deficiencies the food uh
bad fuels that we use for cooking and
all this kind of stuff
and so that's that book is was named
hell's kitchen after that district in
new york city hell's kitchen where
everything bad happened so they named it
that district hell's kitchen so we took
that name and put it to the title of the
book because the same thing happening
here with nutrition
and everything bad is happening
it's hell's kitchen it's the cooking
methods it's the nutritional
deficiencies
and my doctor said don't waste my money
on taking vitamins minerals just eat
well and get everything i need and
rebecca said one of the most important
things that anybody can say
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blanket around the crust of the
earth they current veins like gold and
silver
okay also
plants do not make minerals plants can
make vitamins and amino acids and fatty
acids but plants cannot make minerals
plants only need three minerals
npk
to
produce
seeds in the next generation of that
particular plant
and so you're only 57 sharp if
only those three
okay so you have to consciously
proactively do the right thing and
that's why we have
the cd in the book it's all on your head
that's why we have the book
um epigenetics that's why i have the
book dead doctors online we started all
this okay
okay
uh people always ask me how did you get
involved in this walk you you you were
just a veterinarian well yeah but i
discovered the first mass tie off in
america from pollution okay got it
published in 1965
and when i was in africa working on the
white rhino project to save the white
rhino there's only 300 left in natal
south africa now there's 21 000 because
of our efforts of building wild animal
parts and also
we used a tranquilizer
it was ten thousand times there you go
the tranquilizer was ten thousand times
more potent than morphine so we didn't
have to use
um
uh
darts the size of a uh you know a can of
coca-cola or rebound or something like
that or a flashlight we were able to use
tranquilizer darts the size of a triple
a battery and knock down these rhino and
um get them into boxes train them
there's only 300 left we brought 200
back to the united states
and today there's
21 000
in africa because of our work so we're
very very proud of that
and this all goes back to this basic
stuff
walk if i may interrupt you because
there's a portion of that story that you
don't share that i think is so vitally
important
in your research and preparing and
bringing these rhinos back to the states
you were working on
creating
actual wildlife reserves
there in africa that's correct creating
habitats that then provided the
nutrients needed that were missing that
were the underlying cause of their
die-off that's correct yeah we built um
waterways we built ponds and lakes uh to
put water in the town zululand south
africa
and
today those big wild animal parks we
established back
and uh see here it was 1965
to 1967
when they got the grant and pulled me
out of africa
we had already brought back 200 right
around the united states but they had to
be trained it took anywhere
from
four to six to eight weeks to train them
uh to live in this box because when we
shipped them from africa to the united
states
they were on a boat in this box
for
two to four weeks to six weeks sometimes
depending what route they took okay and
so they had to be fed and cleaned up
after and watered and everything taken
care of in those boxes for anywhere from
two to six weeks
and we had to train them to do that
and so i mean all this was going on
uh okay and um
there's pictures of all the various um
people who are involved
in that project
operation rhino okay
there's lots of pictures yeah lots of
pictures rhino express so there's no
doubt i'm telling you the truth because
you can see everything i've just
described to you the photographs were
taken in there and put in you know the
proper perspective you know and sequence
and everything as things are happening
um we're trying to save a species we're
down to 300 individuals by actual count
and today by actual count as of december
of last year was 21 000 so we're so very
proud of all the work we did to save the
white rhino and that is the result
of all the work we did and published in
rhino express
this is a great book
for kids who are interested in
conservation working with wildlife
good tells you
um you know we didn't have a lot of
money but we had willpower and we made
it happen and so rhino express is a
great book for kids
who are in the scouting both for girls
and boys who want to get into the
wildlife management um
thing who want to save wildlife we want
to save the earth because we save the
animals we save ourselves so thank you
so much rebecca for getting that cd out
it's a great um
uh summer summary of all the good work
we did
in africa and the book that's all in
your head
uh very important
uh the 25 different diseases in the book
on your head but now when we when you
know when we get down to the last couple
of cases of that book we're going to
reprint it but it'll have another
chapter or two added to it to add those
other
diseases that are
attached to osteoporosis of the skull ms
and alzheimer's disease
okay over to you
all right thank you so much dr wallach
for that introduction and
you know that's that's pretty big and it
really makes you think folks that
you get research and it's printed and
then
it's 16 years later
even the writers that were involved in
that research
are admitting
it was not truthful
well dr wallach has been sharing the
same story for decades
and he is
published many many times i'm working on
getting an actual count of how many
publications books cds
brochures
all of these medical journal things that
have been published with his research
information
and things are continuing
to be correct
after all these years
and that's one reason why
i am so proud and honored to be able to
host this program and bring this
information to you and make sure that
it's spread around the world
because it doesn't affect just one
community one family one culture it is
worldwide and hello dr milan welcome
we love to see you as well it's all
right doc it's all right because she was
so instrumental in all of this or most
and
this research and the writing of the
books i mean her name's on there too and
she's a brilliant mind as well
and so
okay um milan
come here
rebecca's is saying good things about
you
okay she's saying good things about you
for all the good work you did and all
being a co-author and all the books and
and articles so she's
she's very shy
she is
she is shy and she's very humble dr
wallach and we just
i i just love and appreciate that
quality about her
um and
you know there there are peoples to know
them to love them
it's just holds true all around
well
dr wellick let's go ahead and we have
some hands that are up already
and the first hand that we are going to
go to and
oh she does have some audio today
wonderful brenda teresa
go ahead and unmute yourself you are the
first hand up in our lineup welcome to
ask doc live thank you good morning dr
wallach good morning how can we help you
well i know a man from the uk i'm a
distributor since august 2015 and i know
a man from the uk who has a female cat
that was recently diagnosed with
pancreatitis she is on high protein
grain free food but struggling to eat
but now under the care of the vet i
guess she's getting better she's asking
for food she's highly allergic to dairy
her blood sugar appears to be okay and
not pre-diabetic and i did give him the
instructions for arthrodicks and efas as
well so what can we do to help him with
his sweet little baby okay well that cat
should be getting a commercial cat food
and a moist cat food canned cat food
instead of you know giving it fish and
i'm getting the
idea that this guy is just giving fish
or meat or
chicken livers or something to this cat
um
but it needs to get a high quality brand
from the uk
cat food canned added the arthrodex to
it and then don't forget the efas
um
one or one efa one ef-8 plus the f8 plus
is from
uh
fish livers and efas are from grains
those essential fatty acids are
important here
and um i think everything will come
right okay this is you know camps have
nine lives remember right do you suggest
any ultimate enzymes or anything like
probiotics or for cats
like that for him
not really just that that commercial can
of
moist
cat food and it can be made out of fish
and chicken and beef or whatever it's
made out of but it does have to have
the vitamins and minerals added to it
and then add the arthritis one scoop for
20 pounds of body weight so if you can't
weighs eight pounds we have a scoop is a
cat weighs five pounds it's a quarter of
a scoop of the arthur dex okay okay
sounds great thank you thank you
you're welcome
all right thank you so much brenda
teresa you know we are working with the
um most famous wonderful dynamic vet in
the world because that's where he
started folks
well no he started healing himself and
then he went into agriculture and
veterinary medicine and found which he
did not mention
he found the very first non-human case
of cystic fibrosis
which was then found in that whole
colony
emory university i was i was a
pathologist for nasa at that time
and um
and when i when i found out that it was
a nutritional deficiency by sending
slides to five different medical schools
and i didn't tell them it was from a
monkey i just said i think this is from
cystic fibrosis what do you think they
all wrote back in their letterhead
remember this is 1977. oh yeah this is a
classic example of um cynical roses and
that i told him was from a monkey and at
the very least we had an animal model
now and they went crazy positive until i
asked him let's do
uh biopsies and the other 24 baby
monkeys the colony and they all had
cydia bros says all had different
mothers and fathers i said well this
can't be
uh genetic this has to be a nutritional
deficiency thing
and they fired me and that's when i went
back to school and became a physician
and you took that information dr wellick
and you have helped so many children
and also the prevention of it
yes well we've we
uh
our attorney uh jonathan eboard and i
spent
25 or more years in federal courts
petitioning and suing and partitioning
and suing to get these nutrients into
baby farmers we finally got it done
and in the early 1990s
okay suddenly now citigross has
disappeared suddenly now muscular
dystrophy disappeared suddenly now
um sediment death syndrome disappeared
now it shows you how silly the medical
system is how tragically silly they are
because from the from the um son of a
death syndrome sids
uh what what did doctors say cause sis
they said that mothers were laying on
their babies in the bed and suffocating
during their sleep
and for 25 years these mothers where the
babies were dying of
of um sentiment death syndrome they're
committing suicide because their
churches were excommunicating them their
families were excommunicating them their
neighbors were dissing them because they
had killed their own baby by sleeping on
them well that wasn't true
they were dying of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease and dr
milan and i went to china we did one
thousand seven hundred autopsies and
kids that died of keyshawn disease which
is hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease and got it published
and um
i got the
i said that earlier i think i got the
lifetime achievement award on natural
medicine
from the the um
let's see was it the the
lifetime achievement on natural medicine
and for empathy from the united nations
from united nations and that's yeah
that's
the united nations given me the the
award there at their headquarters in new
york city
okay and they only gave out three of
those
awards since the beginning they don't
give it every year they only give it
something extraordinary and the
discovery
that sediment death syndrome was not the
mothers laying on their babies
was it okay
that came out
in
okay so very very proud of that
award
well it's definitely something dr
wallick that
you know you should be proud of because
that is continuing it's not just
something that you hang on the wall
it's something that you use every single
day
that information in helping people
you're not keeping it to yourself and
that's our goal is to not keep it to
ourselves
because it is life-changing
that you're not going to hear about on
tv
and a lot of people are just plugged
into tv and all of the things that are
going on well let's spread some good
news let's spread some hope let's spread
that we
as people
are empowered
of our own health journey
let's go to the next hand that is up dr
wallach and that is vicky vicki go ahead
and unmute yourself
okay you hear me yes ma'am if you'd like
to come on camera you're more than
welcome to do so but you're on live with
dr wallach okay hi dr wahl
my call you know i called you back at
the end of may and i had started started
youngevity about a month before and i
called you mainly because of migraines
i've got herniated um cervical discs
and basically i kind of wanted to give
you an update
because and ask a question also um one
of the things i didn't mention was that
i had restless leg because it was just
mainly an annoyance and no it wasn't
primary anyway that has disappeared all
of a sudden i wake up i'm reading an
article about somebody having restless
leg i'm like wait a minute i don't have
it anymore so that has disappeared and
my migraines have reduced
okay my question is
you had recommended i go on the collagen
i got the collagen peptides
and i was taking them but i was getting
a lot of gas
so i ended up stopping them and i wanted
to get your recommendation of what to
take instead of that or
what's going on with that maybe how much
you weigh how much you weigh oh i weigh
um
what 126 i'm 5'3
and how old are you
uh 67.
okay
uh do you have any ringing in the ears
or tinnitus or
dizziness okay how many times you wake
up at night to urinate once five times
ten times
maybe once
okay
and let's see here
do you have anything going on
with this restless leg syndrome do you
have anything going on uh in your lower
back uh you know have they talked about
surgery in your disc have they talked
about hip replacement knee replacement
anything like that
no
okay all right
well you have a combination of things
which is not unusual okay have multiple
problems now the restless leg syndrome
is caused by osteoporosis of the skull
uh squeezing the spinal cord
okay
um the degenerative disc disease you
have
um
headaches okay these migraine headaches
go along with trigeminal neuralgia which
is the stiff cranial nerve squeeze you
get headaches behind the eyes on the
temples on the cheeks and behind the
ears all those kind of stuff big
headaches okay that's the fifth cranial
nerve being squeezed by the skull
and so at 126 pounds with all this stuff
going on here i'd have you take one
healthy brain and heart pack per month a
half a dose everything twice a day but i
want you to take an extra bottle of
ursuline not from walgreens but
obviously with five cofactors that's
very important here i want you to take
three of those
um
uh selenium twice a day and then i want
you to take the collagen peptides take
um let's see here i want you to take um
a scoop of that your breakfast drink
again a scoop of your evening drink i
want you to take two bottles a month
over msm so you can take three at
breakfast street lunch you dinner time
they're going to help rebuild the disc
between the vertebrae
all the bones in your legs and back and
so on in your skull
and so this is you need to take more
than just one product you need to take
the 90 essential nutrients again that
healthy brain and heart pack and so um
has 215 nutrients in it including the
basic 90 which is the core
and it's the fact that you know you're
not doing it all you're seeing
improvement here there and yawn so let's
get it all gone okay well the thing is
i'm getting gas from the collagen that
was my concern
okay well if you're concerned about gas
from the collagen what i would do is as
you say take the ultimate enzymes go
ahead and take two or three of those say
five or ten minutes for each meal a
couple ounces of water
okay
okay i have one last question
okay i have a dog who i think has pica i
don't know if i'm pronouncing it right
he's he's a nine-month-old 30 pound
dog and he's eating drywall
i thought maybe he has a mineral just
fish or something what do you think
probably does what are you feeding him
it is a
brand that the breeder recommended okay
is it dry is it dry dog food or candy
it's dry and then i add a little bit of
this canned wet which is a liver product
okay
yeah so you need to i'd go for totally
for the canned product with all the
vitamins and minerals in it make sure
make sure there's no gluten in it uh our
arthrodex at um 30 pounds uh it's a
scoop and a half of the arthrodex and in
the food
don't forget the efas i go ahead and
give one efa one efa plus in there and
then call us back in two weeks and four
weeks and six weeks so i'd say you and
the dog you will both be happy
okay
thank you
you bet thank you
all right
back to you becca
all right thank you vicky so dr wellick
we have several questions that are
coming in the chat
um so let's go to the first one and
we're going to try to hit these all in
order
um so david says good morning i've been
eating gluten for 67 years in the past
two months i have given up the
bad foods and started on the healthy
brain and heart pack
question is approximately how long does
it take for the intestinal villi to
recover
three months six months 12 months
well i would say give us i always say
give us 90 days of course and that's
assuming that they're taking the 90
essential nutrients and better yet if
you've been eating gluten for 67 years
i'd have him take
the
um
and apologize did he say how much he
weighed
no he does not say
okay well let's just say let's get him
on two
brain and heart packs
per month the photos everything twice a
day the collagen peptides the scoop
without a breakfast a scoop of dinner
and the drink uh the msm two bottles of
that per month three breakfast at lunch
at dinner time
and um
it's
see here vitamin d3 through those twice
a day
and
these complaints will all go away if you
have some white greens over here the
hair color will come back because
the loss of hair color is not due to
aging it's due to nutritional deficiency
and the same nutritional deficiency that
produce white grain cellular hair also
cause plaque in the arteries and
fibromyalgia and all kinds of other
stuff so
you want to make sure that hair color is
coming back not because you're coloring
it and dying it but because your body is
now producing the pigment because you're
getting the nutrients okay
yes and i know that it's possible
because this spot right here used to be
all white dr welling
wow so
yeah i'm excited
ruth ellen had a message message to her
that says
um
would you ask doc what the secret sauce
is for vascular issues especially in the
lower legs
i've had both hips replaced and i've
been dealing with numbness in the upper
legs and some redness or purplish
purpleness rather in lower legs
especially the left leg i'm using the
2.5 pack
um an alternate with ultimate daily
classic and pro cardio fx
what else do i need
sev so
this individual and i love this dr
wallach
80 years old
and she still realizes that the body
needs nutrition
in order to keep going and it's you
don't have to have pain going forward
so she
did she say how much she weighed i i
didn't get that written down did she say
how much she weighed yep she's 170
pounds at five foot four
okay all right well what i would do
again just for our greater listener
population as well uh get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no wheat bar
right now so sugar no carbon or drinks
and when i say no fried foods i mean no
air frying no deep frying or pan frying
no frying
okay
and then absolutely no sugar including
uh no um
let's see here
no carbonator drinks because even diet
drinks have carbonation they'll
neutralize stomach acid so you cannot
absorb minerals
and digest food
you need your stomach acid so 170 pounds
i wanted to have two healthy brain and
heart packs per month
okay uh two bottles a month of the msm
so you can take three with each meal
that's going to help rebuild cartilage
and ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue and discs between a vertebrae
skin walls of arteries and veins very
important here for her um then i also
wanted her to have the collagen peptides
a scoop of that at breakfast drank a
scoop of that with dinner drink i wanted
her to have
the
um
let's see here she needs to take the
um um what did you have this morning
oh what did i have this morning i had a
lot this morning no no no no no no no no
you opened up a new bottle to take
something
synaptic yes
i had called you and i had shared some
of the things that i was going over yeah
experiencing after a little fender
bender last yesterday and you suggested
sunaptiv yeah okay same thing for her
she needs a synaptic
okay she could take the two or three of
those twice maybe two bottles a month
with synaptic i want her also
um to
um let's see here take vitamin d three
in her asians vitamin d three three of
those twice a day there's two bowels a
month and for the vascular stuff i want
her to get two bottles a month of the
ultimate daily classic tablet so she can
take three at breakfast and three at
dinner time and they'll support healthy
blood flow through blocked arteries in
the brain the heart the kidneys the
lungs every place
and
she will
what should i say make things happen
by getting that blood flowing and also
support healthy blood pressure don't
call turkey off of any medication if
she's on medication but as the blood
pressure drops she can
slowly reduce the
medication
okay all right thank you so much dr
wallach let's go to the next hand that
is up and that is richard richard go
ahead and unmute yourself
and if you'd like to come on camera with
us that would be fantastic
hello doctor hello
yes sir
how do i help you
okay uh let's see i um i weigh 122
pounds my weight
at my height is uh five feet three
inches my age is uh 72
and i uh been diagnosed with advanced
prostate cancer and we'll probably have
to go under some type of radiation
treatment is probably what they're going
to suggest when i see the monday
my concern is that they're talking about
something called
adt
which is referred which is
um
and
androgen
deprivation
therapy
and which means they're gonna what that
means is they're gonna they're going to
cut back on your male hormones uh yes uh
do you consider that good or bad
well um
male hormones will drive prostate cancer
okay so
um you know that's something that you
you have to pray on decide that that's
what you want to do
if you want to
do that
is going to at the very least slow down
the growth of prostate cancer okay so
that's not a bad thing
um and then sometimes you just have to
have sex even though you're not driven
to have sex you just have sex because
you know you should have fun and all
that kind of stuff but it's one of those
things where you're not going to be
driven to have sex if you're taking
those drugs okay
then
um your body weight 122 pounds i want
you to have one healthy brain and heart
pack per month to support the immune
system i want you to take a half of
those everything twice a day split it up
i want you to
take uh let's see here one bottle a
month to the msm so you can take three
breakfast three at lunch
or three breakfast for dinner time or
two three times a day for a total of six
and that's going to support the immune
system i also want you to take the
collagen peptides that will support the
immune system by helping you make white
blood cells and red blood cells and
platelets and antibodies and so on your
bone marrow
okay that's going to help you a lot
and so that's where i would go there do
not take any
of the prostate support nutritional
programs you know prost effects and that
kind of stuff don't take those things
because you don't want to be driving
the nutrition can't determine can't
differentiate between
cancers prostate cells and normal
prostate cells so you don't want to be
driving
prostate cells when you're when you're
being treated for prostate cancer okay
um but you do want to take these
nutrients also the collagen peptides go
ahead and take a scoop of that with your
morning drink and scoop without your
evening drink
don't forget the vitamin d3 three of
those twice a day
and um let's go there
okay
okay and the first thing you said was
the uh the health pack
healthy brain and heart pack
okay
all right fine thank you very much yeah
keep in touch okay let us know how
things are going okay
all right sure enough okay thank you
richard
bye-bye
all right thank you richard and just so
everybody knows the replays for all of
our programs of ask askdoc live can be
found on our website askdoclive.com
including today's which will be
available
through the weekend or by the weekend i
should say and then available for who
knows how long we have programs that
have been on there for more than two
years stock i love the fact that we can
use technology to be able to share
and we do encourage you that if you are
on
live with us or watching the replay get
back with the person that shared this
program with you
they cared they have a vested interest
in making sure that
you have better health because they want
to keep you around folks
i know for myself i was in a bad place
and now to see other people
struggling
and hurting and in a bad place it just
breaks my heart because i know it's not
necessary it's
you give the body what it needs dr
wallach and you've
you've proven it time and time again
you put those nutrients into your
formulas they synergistically
work together you actually get
absorption
into the cells where the nutrition is
needed
not just peed out into the
septic system or whatever system you're
on
the body can do some amazing stuff
yeah with that said i want to go back to
that minnesota paper that was written in
2006. we didn't spend much time on that
um we're i think there's somewhere
between 12 and
15 contributors to that paper it was
considered the
ultimate paper and when it came to
um
uh
alzheimer's alzheimer's right yeah yeah
and so
apparently there's one or more of those
authors that twisted the data a little
bit and tinkered with the
pictures of the
damage in the brain
um the demyelination of the brain
and so forth
and so they gave a lot of misinformation
out when people inquired about more
information and so forth they gave out a
lot of misinformation and it's coming
back to haunt them now
okay because um once very well respected
university university of minnesota now
their medical school is really under
extreme scrutiny
because of the misinformation
perpetrated by that paper on alzheimer's
disease
yeah most definitely
most definitely now dr wallach you
mentioned collagen a lot
and cynthia has a really good question
she says
can i sprinkle the collagen peptides and
the osteoaffects powder on my food
instead of putting it in my drink
yes you can put it in apple sauce you
can put in your mashed potatoes
you can sprinkle it on your salad
uh it really doesn't have any taste
it's just kind of a white crystalline
powder it's made from from collagen from
cartilage and ligaments and tendons and
connective tissue from fish poultry
sheep and beef it's really a very
interesting product
and of course our original
collagen product was glucogel
okay that was our original that we put
together
of with the healthy bone and joint pack
for theo ratliffs a great basketball
player who came back from totally losing
his contract so he's 24 years old and
had bone to bone arthritis in both knees
and his cartilage popped off his hips um
he had a fracture and a wrist and a
shooting arm he lost his contracts but
after a year in our program and we built
the healthy um
let's see here the healthy
bone and joint joint yeah healthy bone
and joint pack for him
um with that collagen okay the um
again uh the glucogel
uh he came back
and played for 11 more years and made
over 100 million dollars do you think he
likes our products
i i think he might appreciate them just
a little bit
he's been very good
about telling his story and that's why
we have his picture on the label of our
cans and our boxes of rebound that's the
guy who made it all happen
theo wrapless
awesome and i actually cynthia i mix my
i even did rebound this morning in my
plain yogurt but i will mix my collagen
in there i will mix osteo effects i'll
mix my tangy tangerine dr judy is
holding up her
cup where she has in their collagen as
well i know she is loving the collagen
and as a researcher herself and
developer
in the animal world of feeds collagen is
so important
not just for skin folks
we're talking about every
strand
of connective tissue
we're talking about tendons muscles
ligaments
um for those of you who are getting your
steak those
little that marbling in there
you know that's all part of connective
tissue
and
we need it in order to keep our
connective tissue healthy and strong
let's go to some questions so
in the chat here mark had asked is there
an upper limit to the temperature we
should be using to bake food in the oven
to avoid the acrylamide or other
problems from overcooking food
well of course
there's
others
want to
in fact that'll be a good question to
look up and i'll have the exact answers
um by next week okay on that question
but
you always want to when it comes to meat
you want medium rare or rare you don't
want medium wells
and you don't want to burn the fats
folks that's right you do not want to
burn the fats or connective tissue and
don't forget your heart valves
are made out of that same collagen your
heart valves and all the tendons and
ligaments that hold the heart valves to
the heart muscle
and when the heart contracts
those ligaments and tendons pull the
vowels and so that's how all those
valves everything work in the heart but
they require even the heart
and and the covering on the brain
okay
uh the covering on the brain
is made out of um the connective tissue
okay so you need you need that that um
stuff for just about every tissue in the
body
blood vessels arteries veins lymphatic
vessels
everything and your hair
yeah hair
because of the skin
i was going through this morning getting
ready and then all of a sudden i just
kind of like puffed my hair i'm like i
have happy hair dr wallach and one of
the only things that i've done is i've
added two more doses of collagen a day
there you go i love it
absolutely love it let's go to the next
hand that is up and saint theresa's
iphone
go ahead and unmute yourself
and is it therese maybe
go ahead and say something i see you're
unmuted
hello
welcome to our stock live
i'm not hearing anything
okay well maybe the camera came on but
it's a black screen so i'm wondering
maybe uh go back out of the meeting and
come back in and let's see if we can get
a better connection for you and while
she's doing that we've got a few more
minutes here patricia would like to know
what's good for tinnitus and vertigo dr
wallach
so okay let's say five foot six
female
174 pounds
okay
well when you have tinnitus ringing in
the ears
and vertigo as the eighth trail nerve
being squeezed when you when you're
getting tinnitus ringing in the ears
it's the auditory branch of the eighth
grader being squeezed when you have
vertigo
balanced dizziness problems that's the
vestibular branch the age trailer being
squeezed and if you really think about
it you have other symptoms of
osteoporosis of the skull
okay and so at 179 174 pounds gives me
174 pounds need
um to get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no we need to buy rhinos no
sugar no carbohydrate drinks
and um
even the diet one's got to go
and don't forget that sometimes
getting up at night uh you know two
three four five six eight ten times has
to do with osteoporosis to the skull
also squeezing the spinal cord the
spinal cord is sending messages to the
urinary bladder to urinate
and it's not a prostate issue because
women don't have prostate glands women
do have four times the rate of
osteoporosis in men so that's why they
have so many of these things well this
should go very very quickly and
you know we don't know do you have high
blood pressure you have diabetes you
have skin problems you have irritable
bowel syndrome
uh do you have diverticulitis you have
crohn's disease
uh did you have your panics out when
you're a kid there's a lot of questions
i would ask you if this was a live
interview instead of a instead of an
email
all right thank you so much dr wellick
let's go to i have another question here
from cynthia wait okay wait a minute i
don't know if i said everything she
needs oh did i say collagen peptides a
scoop of that with each uh her morning
drink or evening drink she needs the
um msm um two of those so she can have
the two bottles a month so you have
three with breakfast through the lunch
dinner time that's in addition to the
two healthy branded heart packs
okay and then vitamin d three three of
those twice a day and that will help get
rid of the tinnitus and ringing the ears
and the
vertigo the balance and dizziness
problems but also all the other stuff
that's going on
um
which can be more fatal
okay and so um it's just not a bad thing
when you get these early warning signals
you make the adjustments in your diet
and you take the supplement program
properly to get the nutrients necessary
for the skull to repair itself and again
this is where
uh the book it's all on your head
and the cd it's all in your head it
should be a must
this is a must uh for this um
uh lady okay for patricia
for for theresa is it patricia oh
patrice oh patricia okay there's the
second one okay patricia okay yeah so
she needs to get a hold of the book
and the cd and they will be live saving
her for her
all right thank you so much dr
can i go forward now
yes okay let's go to cynthia's uh
question that she had put in the chat
and it is in regards to a sick 76 year
old male
148 pounds
six foot tall
his health concern is that he had an
infected knee
it was on heavy cortisone and antibio
antibiotics
now they want to give him weekly
injections in his belly to keep the
inflammation down
is there a good protocol to
heal the knee
reduce inflammation and prevent him from
having this weekly injection
yes he should change doctors immediately
go to a medical school
because this doctor probably has a kid
in college and they need tuition so he
wants a weekly treatment so he can pay
the tuition for the kid
okay
and so um
when you have
joint problems
and you're
um 148 pounds
um 76 years old the odds are you have
some things going on
in your body from several things so get
rid of all the bad foods
okay the odds are that cynthia has
um a gluten issue the only people who
are not sensitive gluten are dead people
so
no um fried foods no processed meats no
oils or glutens and wheat and whatever i
know so sure no carburetor drinks even
the diet one's got to go
and then i would have her 148 pounds
she's right on that cusp so we're going
to go full bore here uh take two healthy
brain and heart packs per month to
photosynthetic twice a day two bottles a
month in the msm so you can take three
of breakfast straight lunch at dinner
time and they're gonna support and
promote mainstream pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone ranks
bone itself including the knees and the
hips and the back and the shoulders and
ankles and wrists and all that kind of
stuff
then uh she needs the collagen peptides
to scoop with that in her morning drink
and scoop it in her eating drink she
also i'd never take the beyond osteo fx
uh plus
it comes in three forms it comes in the
powder i use the powder i put a scoop of
that in my morning drink in my evening
drink along with the collagen peptides
comes in capsules if you want to take
three or four or five of those twice a
day capsules comes in a liquid you can
take an ounce of that twice maybe two
quarts a month okay and it will um this
combination of stuff
uh will
uh rebuild all the ligaments and tendons
and connective tissue and walls of
arteries and veins in your skin
and and so on and including the knees
and the
tendons
and so on
this is very simple stuff
but doctors want to do cortisone and
painkillers because it makes the patient
happy oh my god i was in pain the doctor
gave me i shot a cortisone three days
later my pain was gone i just let my
doctor when i die i'm gonna leave
everything in my will to my doctor
because he got rid of my pain
okay
well you better start riding that will
because you're gonna die early if that's
all you did was get cortisone to deal
with all these bone and joint problems
because you are gonna die early
okay so
this is all easily dealt with i always
say give us 90 days but you'll see great
results long before that how long do i
have to stay on the diet how long do i
have to stay on the
program by consciously proactively
taking these essential factors as long
as you need oxygen and water
which means as long as you're alive
all right thank you so much dr wallach
and let's try saint teresa's
phone again go ahead and unmute i see
your beautiful smiling face i think we
might have a good connection now hi how
are you uh hi rebecca it's marla
in kansas city
my phone says funny things hi doc
my question is i um have been
pre-diabetes for a while even though i
exercise and eat intelligently and i do
supplement so i think the other factor
stress i may not be managing it real
well but i look happy on the outside i
don't get it but my a1c recently was 6.0
and doc i want to know is it possible to
have reactive hypoglycemia
concurrent with a a
a high blood sugar can it bounce back
and forth
of course you have to appreciate the
pre-diabetes
6.1 is pretty close to normal you know
6.1 okay
okay 6.0 but yeah
6.0 okay it's pretty close to five
okay
okay and so if you were 14 i'd be
worried
well i'm having symptoms there are times
i have blackouts and rebecca knows him
okay you have to stop talking a minute
so i can answer the 18 questions you
answered i'm sorry
so basically when you have reactive
hypoglycemia you eat a big meal
especially with carbohydrates and
potatoes rice bread
um
that sort of stuff
okay um
you get your body's throwing out more
um when you're pre-diabetic
your body throws out more uh insulin and
drops your blood sugar down and you pass
out this is why there's so many
accidents on the highway when people get
killed
uh for you know they cross the center
line to a head-on with somebody and both
cars go in both directions and the
drivers are dead
because the one who crossed the center
line
when they do drug tests on them they
didn't have any drugs in them so what
was going on well they never take their
blood sugar
they never take their blood sugar see
and what's happening is these are the
people who when they're at home they eat
a big deal a big dinner especially with
carbohydrates in it you know a couple of
baked potatoes kind of stuff
okay or drink a couple of uh diet cokes
um
they'll go to sleep even when they're
driving they'll just go to sleep and
cross the center line
and so that's what happens there when
you have reactive hypoglycemia so
you want to take the healthy brain and
heart pack one per hundred pounds of
body weight you want to take our
sweeties go ahead and take um
uh two or three of those twice a day per
hundred pounds of body weight we don't
even have your body weight here and so
100 100 pounds five one
okay so so in your case uh i'd get you
know one bottle of sweeties per month
and i'd go ahead and take um go ahead
and take
three of those twice a day take three at
breakfast reading at a time or you could
take two at breakfast two at lunch with
dinner time for total six a day
and then you know continue
and you don't need um to get a
prescription from your doctor to get the
test strips from a pharmacy uh go get
those so you can monitor your own blood
sugar uh say a half hour an hour two
hours after you eat and see what's going
on there you can do that yourself and
don't have to run up a 500 building do
all the lab work in the office and all
that kind of stuff it'll cost you you
know about 50 for the test strip
okay
yeah i actually have some and i guess i
can start using i didn't know glucose
strips would tell you the same as your
a1c but i'll say well see it doesn't
tell it doesn't matter whether you have
low blood sugar or high blood sugar it's
going to tell you what your sugar level
is
okay and so i just need to learn how to
eat so i don't spike it and take the
supplements
that's right
well you got to take the 90. and i'll
take that 100 pounds one healthy brain
heart pack per month half a dose
everything twice a day um one problem
msm so you can take three of those twice
a day take the sweeties
okay at very least take um one bottle a
month so you can take uh say uh one
uh three times a day for with your
sweeties
okay and okay and and and you know give
us a call in two weeks and four weeks
and six weeks because people want to
hear because this is a very common
problem
okay so i could have both high blood
pressure at times and low blood pressure
at times it could swing in a given day
wait a minute are you talking about
blood pressure or sugar no i meant blood
sugar i mean blood sugar can it swing
too high blood sugar that you're
reacting sometimes and low blood sugar
yeah yeah it depends on what you're
eating
okay all right i sure appreciate it i
have to learn to eat better they want to
give me a nutrition through the blue
cross program i know it won't be a
holistic but i can probably consult with
rebecca and get some yeah yeah well
rebecca is a good coach
of course okay that's and it wouldn't
hurt for you to get that book um rare
urban cures go to chapter 10 it'll tell
you how to collect hair
uh so you're doing things scientifically
um
and a couple weeks you'll get the
two charts back one chart we'll tell you
about the essential
uh nutrients minerals okay
um
and that's very important and then also
type you have any a second chart we'll
type you have toxic minerals like lead
mercury okay and
uranium and stuff like that okay it's
called rare earthman cures
and you want to get it and so you get
chapter 10 it'll tell you how to collect
the hair you cannot get this information
with blood tests
right
rare earth cures e-a-r-t-h rare earth
forbidden cures
oh rare earth's forbidden cures okay
thank you doc
thank you thank you so much thank you
thank you
thank you all right thank you
thank you nice to see your face you too
let's go and take a break doc
we are at the top of the hour
you are listening to ask doc live and we
just want to make sure that you are
getting the information that you need
in order to
reclaim
your health journey
because you have power you have it
within you
to be able to choose
your future health journey
my name is rebecca dukes kozak and we
will be right back after this short
break on a stock live
all right we are back here with ask doc
live my name is rebecca dukes kozak and
if you're on live with us make sure that
you have that chat box open
our co-hosts are putting some amazing
information in that chat
and
you can put your questions in the chat
as well if you don't feel comfortable
raising your hand but please raise your
hand we try to get to all of the hands
raised first as we're going through the
program is we want to get
we want to get real answers people to
the people that are here with us
and to find that raised hand option go
to the zoom menu click on reactions and
you'll see a little button that says
raise hand like russ just found good job
for us um we have a couple questions dr
wallach that i would like to let's go
ahead and get you unmuted
that i would like to ask that have been
asked in the first part of this program
and
now i can hear you
yes
okay so okay
john
has a question here he says good morning
this question is for doc my question is
how long should it take in your opinion
for me to have relief of the pain in my
hip i'm taking the optimal amount of the
healthy body pack let me get to the
healthy brain and heart pack
along with your recommendations of the
secret sauces i am gluten free i removed
all the bad foods eating six eggs a day
in the process of calorie restriction
and adjusting these foods i've also
started exercising mainly walking and
stretching and i am using the hip pain
as my gauge for healing now i have to
say
as a coach
and you have somebody come to you
asking questions wanting your
recommendations
they follow the recommendations that's
like a coach's dream dr wallach and john
is right there as
a coach's dream
so he's just started on the program in
the last 60 days
he's feeling great
but he is using a hip pain as a monitor
for
kind of using the reconstruction of the
hips instead of having
hip replacement
do we have any type of indication when
he's following all the rules about how
long
through your autopsies and research
yes
okay basically what you have to do i'm
assuming you can still hear me is that
correct yes i hear you
okay okay we need to make a list of all
the symptoms those may have 18 different
symptoms but he's sort of fixed on that
hip pain okay because the doctors want
to give him a hip replacement so he
needs to make a list of all these
symptoms i always tell people give us 90
days
but you're going to see
some of these things improve within
three days
had people who
were blind and then in three days time
they could go get their driver's license
and freaking everybody out okay and so
what surgeon did you go to i didn't go
to surgery i just changed my
diet and took these supplements and my
vision came back because they had
osteoporosis to the skull okay it wasn't
an eye problem it was osteoporosis of
the skull and so
um
you get miracles like that and then
sometimes
if the circulation is obstructed
into the heart or the brain or a joint
or something like that it might take 60
days to see complete resolution or some
significant
improvement okay
and so uh some things are going to go
faster than others
so you can't give in you know
uh a fixed amount of time
but make a list of all the various
things that are going on from the skin
the hair color
um
and so forth uh bowel movements uh
that kind of thing
and then
skin issues
tinnitus balance
and so on as i said hair color digestion
uh hiccups
all these things write them all down
pain
um
restricted range of motion
and then
okay um
for instance i can walk all day i'm 83
years old i can walk all day and never
stop but i walk three miles a day uh i
walk one mile and then maybe an hour and
a half two hours later after i've done a
lot of other stuff i'll walk another
mile then a couple of hours later i'll
walk another mile
okay and i do 20 push-ups twice a day
not not bad for 83 years old
okay and so but in the meantime i'm
accomplishing a lot of stuff on the
phone on the computer and and uh so
forth
and so it's and
it's one of those things where don't sit
there waiting by second by second by
second where one thing is gonna you know
be
fixed okay make a list of
all the things that's going on and that
way you say boy 90 of them are already
gone it's only been two weeks
okay and so some of them their advance
issues might take you
three months might take six months
but
if you're getting
rapid
improvement in
three and five and eight and ten and
twelve other issues you're on the right
track
so i hope that's a
uh understandable answer
i think that it is because dr wallach
everything within our body is connected
and when you start getting improvements
in one area it's not just those cells
it's cells throughout the body it just
takes
longer to
can i say rebuild jaunty yeah trying to
be i'm trying to see i don't have i
don't have all the uh alphabet behind my
name like you do which proves anybody
can do this
okay
but
you know the cells within our body
they're all cells
and some of them are soft tissue some of
them are hard tissue
so they take different amounts of time
and as that soft tissue is improving you
got to know that hard tissue is too it
just takes a little bit longer
so i know that's what i experienced
anyways
yeah and i you know just recently had
a guy who had issues and he said well
how long is it going to take i said well
you know give it 90 days
and he caught he calls back in two weeks
and said my problems are all gone
but that doesn't mean you stop taking
what
no no no
how how long you have to do it well as
long as you're needing oxygen and water
you need these 90 essential nutrients
okay because you can't get them from
your food you can't guarantee you're
going to get them from your food because
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blank around the crust of the
earth they turn veins like gold and
silver
and once you truly
appreciate what that says
okay that these nutrients occur in veins
like gold and silver
and that's why there's certain people in
certain areas of the world do very well
and that's why we have um
you know the life expectancy of people
over the world
okay
um interestingly enough one of the worst
ones is russia they their average
lifespan their life expectancy is 72.
okay whereas the people up in hunza
pakistan right on the chinese border
okay in the himalayan mountains is 120.
now that's not their limitation 120 is
their average
okay some of them lived 160.
now they were they were the subjects of
a book and a movie called lost verizon
by james hilton
okay
okay and so this is a very famous story
and he was a new york times investigate
reporter he was a critic boy let me tell
you this guy
they sent him
there to find out what was going on
because all these people claiming
they're all all these long lived ages
and everything is beyond anybody's
beliefs so the new york times sent um
um hilton james hilton up there to
investigate uh dr lee this chinese
doctor running around making all these
people live to be 120. okay
well it turned out it was true
well i'll tell you what dr while like
seven years ago i didn't want to live to
be 120
because i hurt so bad
now
bring it on
well now every time i see you get out of
the car you're dancing into the front
door
and you're dancing up the steps so very
proud of you and you're a good example
of what can be done if you do all the
right stuff
and pass on the message other people
uh i'm very excited we're we're building
a huge team and i can't thank you
and uh astoc live team
um
i can't thank you enough for getting
this information out there
well i love the fact that dr wallach we
can bring everyone together
we don't stick with just our team
we are here for everybody and helping
them have resources that they need in
order to
reach around the world we are not
one man for himself
we are family
and that's like our our co-host team
we're different teams
but we're coming together because we
have the passion of helping others
and i love that
um and we have some questions here in
the chat okay um from more more and i
know some of them are team members but i
think so there's many of them that are
not
and miriam wants to know is there a
supplement program that can help
somebody with a marijuana addiction to
wing themselves off of
it
and then i had an
email that was coming in dr wallach that
you might be able to address at the same
time
on alcoholism
and addiction
so is there nutritional deficiencies
that are kind of
aiding in
being pushed towards addiction in
general
yes whether it's obesity and eating too
much
okay with us
experimenting and trying marijuana or
experimenting and trying alcohol
okay come on santa claus drinks alcohol
grandma used to leave a glass of wine
out for santa claus every
milk always left milk
oh it's the milk of grapes
oh
okay so anyway um yeah you have to
appreciate
that when people have addictive problems
whether it's alcohol whether it's drugs
of any kind
of there's prescription drugs or illegal
drugs
um whether it's um alcohol
okay
or food and and becoming obese
these addictions are all caused by
nutritional deficiencies and the the
patient or individual
develops a behavior called pica p-i-c-a
look it up
i have siri what's the definition of
pica it's an insatiable desire to eat
okay because your body wants stuff
and if you're missing this stuff your
body tells you to eat
[Music]
okay and so if you choose poorly you're
gonna have a bad result alcoholism drug
addiction
uh alcohol
of course
obesity and so forth so it's essential
that you get a hair analysis
when you have this addiction it's called
pica pika p-i-c-a
pike is the name given to this
and you see this in animals
okay um
in horses they call it cribbing where
the hearts put them in their soul at
night and they sit there they eat the
top rail and their stall though you come
back in the morning they're the top rail
and the salt is eating through
well why is that
well that's because the horse is missing
something and the horse's brain is
telling them you better eat and get this
stuff and the only thing that he had and
within reach was that top rail in the
stalls it's called cribbing
but in humans it's called pica when
babies do that in their crib it's called
cribbing
okay they're missing stuff
and of course the baby's not going to
get um alcoholism or drug addiction
unless the mother is doing that and
breastfeeding the baby so the drugs and
the alcohol are coming through the
breast milk
i've seen babies that were just you know
three months old that were addicted to
drugs we're in the heck to get that well
the mother's addicted to drugs they're
coming through
the breast milk okay
and so
um this is very basic
biological stuff
okay and of course again
um it's it's in the book of things like
dead doctors don't lie the cds in nine
languages get a hold of that book rare
error has been cured you've got a
hearing losses
you'll be amazed go to chapter 10 tells
you how to collect the hair where to
send it
uh don't forget to write the check and
send it with it because lab won't run
the test without the check
and it's one of those things where
this is very very simple it's been well
established over the years and we deal a
lot with people who have pike and
they're obese
and the reason why our weight loss
programs work is because we not only
deal
with cutting calories but we deal with
giving them the nutrients that are
necessary to make them stop eating
okay so when doctors give you a
prescription
okay
for obesity
um what they're doing is giving you
something to change your metabolism or
this and the other which is not the
right answer
okay you need to stop
eating
well if you're missing these nutrients
you have pica you're just going to eat
25 meals a day
okay and that's how we got in trouble
and guilty um
hello
i was guilty
oh
yeah
and so you had pica and once you changed
i'm very proud of you you lost 100
pounds
and you you know you're a very special
person because
um you're sharing your story with other
people
and you know
i which i say you take these
um essential factors
and so you're not eating all day you're
just not eating all day like you used to
do
well and one thing dr wallach
is
media
and another establishment gave me the
permission
because of certain
different things
to eat six meals a day
they were saying that it wasn't healthy
to do a big meal here in a big meal
there or even a medium-sized meal that
you needed to graze all day long because
of my blood type
well you know there's a science called
crapola
yeah that crap bola added on a lot of
weight
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so see that's because doctors
didn't know what's going on and so
they're just looking at all these people
who gain weight or eating all the time
and so they say well that's just in your
jeans
no
no and i i really thought that it
possibly was and i didn't have a weight
issue until i was in my 40s
i was taller than all the other females
in my family i was thinner than all the
other females in my family i had child
number four and oh my goodness it was
like blowing up a balloon
seriously i put on 120 pounds
and over what period of time three
months six months a year
um
so from five months pregnancy then he
was born five weeks early and then i had
put on 60 pounds
and right after he was born within three
months i had put on another third
another 60 pounds
wow
so it was
it was pretty devastating
it really was and no matter what i did
it seemed like i gained more and more
weight that's because you're minerally
deficient and your body is saying come
on girl eat eat find that stuff and get
it
that's that's it i i was like
okay i felt like i was starving all the
time
but they weren't started
you're starving for minerals that's
right when i started on the supplement
program i was able to control those
cravings
and i wasn't even trying to lose weight
weight was not my big condition my my
big issue it was the pain
from the herniated discs from the torn
hip capsule from the migraines from the
all over body pain
that i was experiencing
i just wanted some type of relief
because i couldn't take the narcotic
pills
to kill the pain
i needed something
and i got it
thank you for sharing think about
needing any of that and i could go
you know most of the day
and not even think about needing food
so
it's kind of it's neat
that i don't have my life focused around
food anymore
so
i just focus around my supplements and
getting what i need and feel great see
so now i didn't have something that you
know more about weight gain weight loss
than most doctors do
okay
they think you just have a bad habit you
can't control yourself that kind of
stuff they don't know it's due to a
nutritional deficiency particularly of
minerals
yeah
and it was
simple it was so simple well we're very
proud of you
so simple i wasn't even trying but i
have lots of other people dr wallace
answers also
okay let's go
so
yvonne is writing in for jason which i
didn't see oh jason's back here yay all
right jason go ahead and unmute yourself
perfect timing
you're on live without jason
hey good morning guys
good morning dr baldwin good morning
okay hello how are you okay wait a
minute i'm getting a lot of echo and
feedback here so you gotta watch what
you're doing here so uh how old are you
how much you weigh
i'm a 24 i'm about 170.
okay and what issues do you have you
want to talk about
uh it's not particularly me i don't
have like any issues i'm concerned about
my my boss he just had knee replacement
surgery
i'm sorry back again wait a minute what
kind of surgery
a knee replacement surgery
oh knee replacement okay
and he he got like blood clots after a
few weeks and now he's doing like
physical therapy and
he's in a lot of pain and he keeps doing
the stretches and
i recommended
the products like the osteo effects and
then
okay
all right i got mine okay
okay one of the things you need to learn
ron and you're you're on the right track
so i give you all kinds of kudus and
applaud so thank you for thinking of
your boss and so on but one of the big
mistake people make they want to know
the nutrient
give me the nutrient i'm going to take
that one nutrient
well what about the other 99
okay it's kind of like
what if you have the very best pistons
in your car
okay
and you're out there
sitting on a park bench where the
pistons in your lap
how far are you gonna go with those
you're missing the car yeah now okay
okay and so that's the same thing that
happens when you think about one
nutrient give me that nutrient
oh i have an iron deficiency so i'm
anemic so i took iron but it really
didn't help
well for your bone marrow to make red
blood cells it requires 90 essential
nutrients not just iron
hemoglobin requires iron but for your
bone marrow to be able to make
hemoglobin it needs all 90 essential
nutrients
got it
so
so um he needs
okay at 170 pounds he needs to get rid
of all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meat so all's included now did
he have a knee repair or a knee
replacement
was a replacement okay so he'll have to
he'll have to keep that
um artificial knee forever okay
but he's 59 out i was saying my weight
in age
he's 59 years old
okay 59 years old okay
59 okay
and so about double uh
about double your weight okay
so our age excuse me double your age 59.
so he needs to
um get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed meats oils and gluten
and this includes air frying uh no wheat
bread or oats there's no such thing as
gluten free oats you need to stay away
from sugar no processed meats absolutely
no ham no bacon
no carbonated drinks if he wants to have
energy he can use our rebound we have
the sticks
we have the canister we have the cans
but the cans do have carbonation in them
so i pop my cans
during the evening from the refrigerator
i'll drink it at morning for breakfast
i'll put two of them in there so i can
have one for breakfast one in the
evening but i'll pop another one in the
evening and put it in the refrigerator
so it's off gases and it's flat by
morning okay it gets rid of all the
carbonation
maximize absorption
and then um he needs to
um at 170 pounds take two healthy brain
and heart packs per month two healthy
brain and heart patch per month photos
everything twice a day
then he needs
uh two bottles a month in the msm so you
can take three at breakfast straight
lunch dinner time and they will help
support promote mains repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone makes
your bone itself
and skin and heart valves and all that
kind of stuff uh the walls of arteries
and veins and then also needs the
um collagen peptides the scoop of that
and the breakfast drink scooper that
evening you drink
and if does he have any other issues
like highway pressure or diabetes did
you know of
not that i know i got him on the
cauldron peptide
okay good okay good yeah you know
breakfast scoop of breakfast scoop at
dinner time and then you need to ask me
other questions do you have any other
issues any diabetes and you have a
pressure
um any ringing in the ears
any dizziness you understand what i'm
saying you need to answer a few more
questions here
any hiccups any belching burping
bloating
those kind of things any constipation
diarrhea did he have his appendix out
when he was a kid
that tells you
the only people who are not sensitive to
gluten or dead people everybody's
sensitive to gluten
okay nobody's eating gluten the only
people
that should be eating gluten are doctors
we should save all our gluten and
because we love our doctor so much every
doctor should have gluten five times a
day
okay okay
so let us know how it goes because your
boss will do very very well
because he does have an artificial knee
we will regrow the bones around that
artificial knee
and so it won't wobble around in there
and cause him a lot of pain so you want
to make sure that all his bones his
femur his tibia and fibula and all his
bones in the upper leg the lower leg are
normal and holding on to that knee okay
and that will
prevent a lot of pain
all right thank you so much jason
thank you guys very much have a great
one and yeah god bless
he's he's got it i do i do
i would like to recommend though that
you get a different bottle for your
beyonce tangerine something that's like
bpa glass would be best so you're not
getting those
plastic toxins absorbed into your
nutrient drink there but keep going
buddy
you're awesome
appreciate you guys and everything you
guys thank you
take care
and be safe be safe
so dr wallach i want to go to another
jason though because here we have a
question that's coming in from yvonne
and the let me get back to it i
apologize
so
you said everyone had
so many questions up in the chat it is
fabulous plus the hands we've got
another hand up
but this jason is 50 years old
five foot eight
160 pounds
confined to a wheelchair
with severe trigeminal pain
for days now
um he does have a diagnosis of gombere
syndrome
oh
um because of this he has had three
brain surgeries
how can we help him with the trigeminal
neuralgia pain okay well trigeminal
neuralgia is the fifth cranial nerve
squeezing or being squeezed by
osteoporosis to the skull
he's got guillain-barre syndrome we've
talked about that
um in
okay the cd which came out a year after
the book came out and so there's so many
symptoms of osteoporosis of the skull
and
of ms multiple sclerosis and multiple
sclerosis in kids under the age of 25 is
called guillain-barre syndrome named
after two french
doctors
in 1916
who who described
um ms in kids
uh under the age of 16 okay
this is kind of crazy they're under the
age of 25 1916
and so any rate
this guy here
can find his wheelchair
okay he needs to stop having brain
surgery okay
um trigeminal neuralgia very easy again
fifth cranial nerve being squeezed by
the skull and there's a lot of this
stuff i'm sure is going on is where the
skull is squeezing the spinal cord and
so everything south of there we want to
know how many times in 19 wakes up to
urinate and all that kind of stuff
uh that'll be very important
it'll give some sense of the amount of
damage in there
but
at 160 pounds he said another bad foods
no fried foods no processed meat so oils
of gluten so we pray right now so sugar
no carbohydrate drinks either the diet
one's got to go
use our rebound instead if you're going
to drink the can pop it at night let it
off gas in the refrigerator all night
and drink it in the morning
if you want one in the afternoon also
then put two in the refrigerator at
night but make sure that they're open so
they off gas
carbonation
and
then let's see here uh needs two healthy
branded heart packs per month he's 160
pounds i need two healthy brain and
heart pattern a month the phone is
saying twice a day
he needs two bottles a month of the msm
so he can take three at breakfast three
at lunchtime dinner time
that will support and promote mainstream
pair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes bone itself skin
artery walls vein walls all that kind of
stuff
okay
also the covering of the brain and and
valves in the heart and all need all
these
nutrients okay
and then
um let's see here we want him to have
um the see here we said the msm we also
wanted to have the collagen peptides and
scoop of that in this morning drink it's
on his evening drink we do want him to
use our rebound sports drink
and
uh also we want him to have our ultimate
daily classic tablets we want to have
two bottles a month so we take three at
breakfast three at lunch
um
or three breakfast dinner time and
that's gonna help support healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries everywhere
and support healthy blood pressure and
the fact that he's had brain surgery or
cam been diagnosed with guillain-barre
syndrome we know
that he has
um uh the problems going on
uh with um
the
uh
nutritional deficiency of
a substance called cholesterol so he
needs those three eggs twice a day
with soft yolk salt boiled soft yolk
salt poached salt salt salt scrambling
butter
um i only weigh 142 and i do that okay
and i don't have any problems
but i do that to prevent problems but he
can reverse all his problems
okay and and we get so many people get
out of wheelchairs this is very easy
okay but he's got to do exactly as i
just said
and uh gamboray syndrome i want to know
how old he was when he was diagnosed
with gambra syndrome he's 50 now
was he diagnosed with it when he was 25
when he was
20 when he was 40 i mean when he was he
diagnosed with guillain-barre syndrome
okay but usually it's in kids under the
age of 25 but it's the same disease as
ms multiple sclerosis which has many of
the same
uh symptoms as osteoporosis of the skull
so you can have both at the same time
would not be unreasonable to see
okay but also it's very easy to get rid
of which we just outlined
right thank you dr wahlik and again
everybody there's a lot of information
that's being shared here and i love the
fact that we are touching on so many
different subjects because we're all
individuals we all have
or have had
different symptoms
and if you have a symptom that is being
mentioned today or you know somebody
that is experiencing
with some of the things that we're
talking about
be empowered
give us 90 days
on one of dr wallach's protocol
specifically
for what you are experiencing
your body will thank you
but we want to make sure that you get
back with the person that shared this
program with you
and thank them also
because
it's life-changing
and for somebody who did supplements dr
wallach since i was itty bitty but doing
the wrong ones and then finding the
right ones
and feeling the difference
i can't stop but encouraging others to
to
yeah it's awesome and people you know
they say well i'm taking vitamins and
minerals okay they're taking like 12.
you need 90.
they're taking 25. you need 90.
okay and so and usually they're taking
lots of i even get people say yeah i
supplement every day well what do you
supplement with i take vitamin c well
what else you say well i just take
vitamin c and i eat well
okay well that's why you have 14
different diseases you're on 14
prescription drugs here doctors want to
amputate half your
at least body it yeah take it out
replace it
well and i dr wallace as i'm working
with people i'll have you know a whole
list of things that they're taking but
they're taking this from this company
this from this company this product
singles you know cherry picking
and it's not working together and then
just because something
is a nutrient there's so many different
forms of that nutrient
not all of them
are essential
right
and not all of them can the body
actually absorb and utilize to our
body's best use
and that's what i love about the
youngevity products
is they are formulated to work together
they're in ratios
that through your work
have been determined
to give the best outcomes
so
again we just encourage you to get back
with the person that shared this program
with you
and say okay sign me up i'm giving you
90 days
but when you're feeling fabulous after
those 90 days that doesn't mean you
quit because then you go right back to
what you were doing that got you feeling
horrible in the first place this is a
lifetime deal
it's a lifetime deal
that's right i'm 90 for
life
dr wallach all right guaranteed
well yvonne has another question
and we'll hit real quick and then we'll
go to our next hand that is up
spinal cord atrophy from an accident
that caused spinal fracture for x-ray
and mri
this gentleman's spinal cord is
shrinking over the past 20 years since
the accident and it has caused his
muscle atrophy in hands
and
adductors and legs you might know what
that means
he's 50 years old six foot and a hundred
and seventy pounds
okay
all right
and so you have to appreciate that he
did an accident
okay and he had some injuries i'm
assuming to his neck and his upper back
and whatnot
okay
and so everything south of there
was in trouble
because whether it's your skull
squeezing a spinal cord or an accident
causing scar tissue
to squeeze the spinal cord everything
sounds in there is getting mixed
messages or no messages
okay might even be a circulation issue
as well
okay
and so somebody who's 170 pounds it has
all this
uh spinal cord atrophy okay and muscular
uh atrophy okay it's about everything
um south
okay um
they need to get rid of all the bad
foods it's the same old recipe no fried
food no processed meats no oils no
gluten around no so sugar no
carbohydrate drinks here that one's got
to go and no air frying either okay and
then um in 170 pounds
they need two healthy brain and heart
paths per month and photosynthetic twice
a day they need the msm two miles a
month so you can take three breakfast
straight lines through dinner time to
help support promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone right bone itself which
has to do with the
spinal cord atrophy okay could be blood
supply could be squeezing in the spinal
cord by scar tissue
in the vertebrae and and the disc and
all that kind of stuff
same thing with muscle atrophy it could
be a lack of um
neurological uh talking to the muscles
or
blood not getting
optimally at levels
to the muscles and so on and so
additionally to the msm collagen
peptides just scoop with that with the
morning drinks with an evening drink
i like the ultimate daily classic
tablets take three of those i'd go with
three three times a day and make three
bottles a month or small bottles
and that's going to support healthy
blood flow through blocked arteries and
support healthy
blood pressure
in the brain and the heart and the liver
and the kidneys and all that kind of
stuff
and don't forget
three eggs twice a day it wouldn't hurt
to have three eggs three times a day
with soft yolks soft boiled soft eggs
salt poached soft eggs soft self
scrambling butter soft yolks okay and so
this is very very important to rebuild
uh the spinal cord remember the brain in
the spinal cord is 25 by weight uh
cholesterol do not take statin drugs
okay
only people who want to have alzheimer's
disease
should take sam drugs if you don't want
to have alzheimer's disease don't take
strength statin drugs
this is very well documented
and remember that the normal person the
normal brain and normal spinal cord
person is 25 by weight cholesterol
and
your body makes cholesterol
and your body wants to eat cholesterol
every cell wall in the body contains
cholesterol
and so this is a required nutrient
cholesterol and doctors treat it like
it's the enemy
and that's why we have alzheimer's
disease alzheimer's disease is a
creation of doctors
it did not exist now there's all kinds
of dementias senile dementia okay
hypoglycemic dementia and so forth
all right
but then once they started taking statin
drugs because they falsely believed the
cholesterol caused plaque and blockages
in the arteries they started taking
statin drugs
in the 1950s by 1960 alzheimer's disease
was the biggest disease we had in the
world
spiking like crazy because they're
cutting off the normal supply
of the
nutrients necessary to make and support
the brain mild in the white matter of
the brain and the cell walls and every
cell in the body
so i hope that answers the question
yes thank you so much
so folks
cholesterol is not the enemy
and you take the cholesterol away and
it's just going to open up that can of
worms of issues
in the brain
down low throughout the body
yeah and cholesterol
yeah cholesterol makes up 95 of the
weight of testosterone in estrogen and
so you have all these um
issues you know ed and
menopause all this kind of stuff
these folks need to be eating three eggs
with soft yolks twice a day
get off of statin drugs and they won't
have those issues anymore
so ed
menopause
alzheimer's disease all these things are
a product of misinformation by the
medical system
that's right and i just want to um
thank you dr wallach for all that you do
and i also want to thank the gentleman
that
is uh
if you're responsible for askdoc live
mz michael zurling welcome michael to
the calls always exciting to have you
here if you want to unmute yourself and
say hello please do
hello to everyone to you becca to doc
to dr judy to heather oh my god how many
people am i gonna
uh forget to oh to to ruth ellen to
nasima
oh my god there's naseem t
and
and there's dennis h
uh uh iphoned linda you know that's good
and geez how many people it's gonna i'm
gonna take up the rest of the meeting
greetings
okay okay good good good okay but but
you're gonna be the one you you catch
the hell from my not
you know mentioning everybody okay not
me because i was willing to i was ready
to
okay
yes and thank you michael because we do
we have 63 people online with us right
now and i've seen it higher we are up a
little bit farther but we just want to
thank anita barbara beatrice bill
um
beam at c
kathy christiane
danny denise david dennis dawn donald
fay
g.b gary greg hilda deborah
linda jason john john karen kathy ken
lucy mark maria
miriam myrna
nancy pamela patricia peter robert
shelby
sonya susan
uh tebows
verna and yvonne and win7 old i'm not
sure who that is and then we have area
codes 201
seven one 205-209-240-7116 eight four
seven nine two five
hf and see what can of worms you opened
up michael
thanks so much the only people yeah the
only people missing were paul and mary
uh oh
that you sing don't you
a what don't you have a song
mary
i don't know there are lots of songs
you no no you you don't you don't want
me to sing for for askdoc live do you
that would be awful everybody would hang
up everybody would go away
you don't want you don't want to do that
but doc and i go back with dead doctors
don't lie radio show like 26 years now
it's unbelievable
uh
yeah i mean where did that it just seems
like 26 minutes right doc mm-hmm
yeah we've been doing it a long time
we've helped a lot of people and
we're just very very grateful for the
opportunity to be there for them yeah
that's terrific
so yeah
and you guys are going really strong on
gas stock live that's fantastic so
and you never rest because you're always
doing radio or zoom meetings or
something right
that's why i take the 90s essential
nutrients
that's yes because if you didn't take
the 90 essential nutrients you could not
do as much as you do or anywhere near it
yeah well the odds are i'd be dead
already
right
okay gang well
thank you thank you thank you thank you
mz
always nice to have you here we
appreciate all that you have done to
make this program possible
and
getting doc on the air and around the
world so i'm super excited to be part of
that as well
yeah michael started it all
um you know internationally so very
proud of our association with him
awesome
so you're muted mz but i'm going to keep
you immunity because we have a couple
more hands before the end of the show my
friend
sorry boss
let's go michael
another mike
in a different part of california
unmute yourself you've got a question
for doc wallach
hey doc this is not for me it's for one
of my clients i'm all good
i've been on the on the nutrition for
almost two years now and i don't take
any more medications in my health
beyond excellent anyway i have a client
he's 53 years old
he weighs 170 pounds he's 5'8
and he's got trigger finger i've had him
on the protocol for about nine months
he's retired now but he's a golfer
and he keeps getting trigger finger and
the doctors have put an injection in his
in his hand a few times and that takes
care of it but then it keeps coming back
and they want to do surgery but he's not
going to do that
what could we do for him i mean he's on
the msm three three times a day collagen
healthy brain and heart pack
he exercises diets and he's just going
crazy with his trigger finger
okay well what he needs to do is get
make sure he gets rid of all the bad
stuff no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens even there are no
such things as a good oats because
gluten in oats is called gliadin no
sugar no carbon or drinks even the diet
one's got to go because this the
carbonation neutralizes stomach acid so
you cannot absorb minerals
and digest food at 170 pounds he needs
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month two healthy brain and heart
patterns per month and full dose
everything twice a day he needs two
bottles of collagen peptides so you can
take
um assuming once one
of collagen peptides should take a scoop
of that with this morning drinks go with
this evening drink these two bottles a
month of the msm so you can take three
breakfasts three electric there and
they're designed to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
a vertebrae bone makes bone itself
the trigger finger
uh he could be due to osteoporosis of
the skull squeezing the spinal cord
that's coming out the back end
and um this is very common uh it's
what's called a peripheral neuropathy
and so i'd want to ask him questions how
many times a night does he get up the
urinate does none once three times five
times ten times i want to know
does he have any clicking in his
shoulders or elbows does he have any
clicking on his knees does he have
hammer toes
um and so forth did he have his appendix
out when he was a kid all this stuff
needs to be asked but in the meantime
at 170 pounds uh he needs again
um that
let's see here the msm we talked about
the collagen peptides we talked about he
also needs i'd throw in the beyond
osteofx
uh a dose of that twice or three times a
day okay either the powder the capsules
of the liquid whichever one
and then uh the ultimate daily classic
tablets take three of those twice a day
that's two miles a month to support
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in the brain and the skull and
replace cells and he needs to get a hold
of
the cd
and the book it's all in your head and
read it and he'll say oh my gosh well
here's why i got trigger finger because
it talks about uh these peripheral
neuropathies okay in the book
um
it's all in your head and the cd it's
all in your head these things are all
reversible
but it's a matter of diet and a
supplement program and so he needs those
on the book and the cd so he can read it
every night and and work on it
25 times a day
okay thank you
you bet
all right thank you mike and let's go
right on over to cynthia dr wallach
cynthia go ahead and unmute yourself i
know you had another question as well
okay i can't hear her
okay cynthia
cynthia's question is in regards to i
believe the muscle mass and loss of
muscle
um she has a client or friend who has
been taking lucerna a meal replacement
um to try to help rebuild that muscle
mass now dr wellick the second
ingredient in glucerna is canola oil
well there you go
so share with us a little bit about meal
replacements and and what's needed in
order to
regain muscle mass cynthia i can hear
little bits of noises but i'm not making
out your voice my dear
okay so here we go
um really there needs to be high quality
food of every uh
subdivision of food
okay maybe high quality protein here's
where three eggs uh twice a day with
soft yolks will work um they they need i
for breakfast this morning i had eggs i
had
um let's see here i had chicken of the
sea i had tuna i had rice
i had orange i had my
rebound in the can with it was off gas
from the carbonation
let's see here what else oh i had the
um
let's see here oh i had
the
dairy products okay i dairy products
okay
and so
uh i either have cheese or i'll have
um
yogurt
yogurt yeah that kind of stuff okay for
breakfast so this morning i had two of
those little cups of yogurt
and so on
and um i had tea
and i had the rebound had been off gas
in the can and so it's one of those
things where
i have a big breakfast every morning and
then for lunch i'll have
a couple of cups of mixed salted nuts no
peanuts in there because they cause
a fungus that grows in peanuts causes
liver cancer so i get the ones with no
peanuts in them
and then i also
i had
um
i think pretty much
uh that's it okay i didn't have the
oranges i said that and so on i peeled
the fresh oranges myself
okay
and so this is and then i had all my
supplements
okay i mean
i i take probably about
i don't know 80 different 80 different
supplements every morning
okay
that's a healthy brain heart pack plus
all these other
all these others
i have a whole desk that's covered with
them and i make about 25 30 bottles of
and then when i get down to the last
four or five and make 25 or 30 more
bottles again
and you're a witness i you know when we
are out on the road i'm taking all those
things just like i do when i'm at home i
never fail
and so it's essential
that um you do this constantly
okay
and so the loss of muscle mass
can be due to a lack of nutritional
minerals a lack of nutrition because
blood vessels are blocked
it could be due to calorie shortage
okay all kinds of stuff
get a hair analysis that's a big thing
get the book the
earthman cures go to chapter 10 find out
how to collect the hair we're going to
ship it don't forget to put the check in
there and find out
what level all your nutritional metals
are at are they all below the bottom
line which means you're below you are
not absorbing
if half of them are in the right area
and half or not okay that's easily
fixable
what if
um
you have no toxic metals you've been
thinking all your life you've had toxic
metals because you're in the military
that shocks a lot of people but it gives
you also a lift of a burden that you
don't have to worry about those toxic
metals because
they would have showed up in the hair
analysis you cannot take a blood test to
see
if you have toxic minerals in your body
okay
um and so you might be able to find out
a little bit about that if you get a
biopsy of your liver most people don't
want to get a biopsy of liver so it's
much easier to get what i call a hair
biopsy okay get that book rare has been
cured go to chapter 10
and do that do it once a year
and that'll be a good investment your
health because it tells you what you
need to do to keep everything where it
needs to be
so that's that's my recommendation there
all right thank you so much dr wallick
and if i could get our co-hosts listed
up here with me showing up here with me
because you know everybody
we just want to thank you so much for
joining us here on ask doc live and for
those of you who are on live with us
having your name is so important because
then we can
get you know for some of you have faces
and names and i love that because i talk
to people on the phone all day long
and like
i had never seen her beautiful face
so
i love the fact that we're able to put
faces with names and voices and duck
we're helping people around the world
be able to
get that smile
whether it's on the face down low in the
eyes
in the hair
you know
let's be happy from the inside out folks
and just be excited to take that first
breath every morning as we're getting up
getting out of bed
and being able to look for a new day and
i know for me
with experience
with different things
when my body was not deficient i didn't
have those addictions
i know that's a question a lot of people
ask well what's
what causes addictions well yes
emotional state is going to take a big
part of it but when our brains are
nutrient deficient including the
cholesterol
we're going to have a harder time
processing stuff so we want to make sure
that we are mineral
not mineral deficient we're giving our
bodies every single cell of our bodies
what it needs
so that we can take and step out
and be that light
in a world where there's a lot of people
searching for something different dr
wellick thank you again for joining us
here on askdoc live
we appreciate you jaunty thank you for
putting all the technology together the
astock live website the critical health
news website the newsletters
if you are here because you are part of
our newsletter
or you want to be part of our newsletter
go to criticalhealthnews.com
write and sign up for our newsletter
um and i think the sign up is also on
askdoc live
i can get a yes no maybe he's thinking
about that but i think it's we well
there's a there's a separate newsletter
for askdoc live there we go so hey
i don't know about you but i get spam
mail all day long
but i love the mail that actually gives
me information that's going to help me
benefit life
so
sign up for a mail we promise we won't
spam you we do not sell your information
to anybody or share it
um
it's
it's safe with us
you are watching ask doc live again my
name is rebecca dukes kozak and join us
next time but most importantly share
this video with somebody else
thank you so much thank you so much bye
for rebecca bye-bye god bless bye-bye
god bless